carl sagan the great popularizer of
astronomy was never elected to the
national academy of sciences and many
people think that is because the other
astrophysicist and astronomers didn't
like the fact that he was popularizing
their field and and they thought that he
shouldn't do this that he was cheapening
the field this attitude is expanded in
many ways and biotechnology it seemed
much worse than what carl sagan had had
to do deal with and the reason is is
that in graduate school we are told kind
of never explicitly but it's implicit
that first of all in bile if you're in
biomedical sciences never speculate
about the future or about where your
research result might go in the future
because you don't want to give people
false hopes and unlike astronomy
biomedical science is is geared very
often to curing diseases and so you you
have a breakthrough it's possible that
it might affect diabetes in the future
you know because you've watch your your
thesis advisor and other professors you
know that you say okay we have made this
advance but this is far from you know
we'll cure for diabetes and cure for
diabetes may never happen so don't think
that we're ever going to get there and
the idea that the idea and it's really a
subconscious ideas don't give false hope
to people okay so that's one thing so
don't speculate don't give false hope
the second thing is don't scare people
bio technology is a really powerful
technology and if you scare people with
the kinds of things that could do then
they're going to shut us down we are
doing great research and we're doing
things that are going to help humanity
and because of you speculating you're
scaring people
all and they'll reject the whole thing
you know you tell people about human
cloning you just bring it up and they
want to shut down our research on cells
and so don't don't talk about that so
those are very strong kinds of feelings
that other people have and I've gotten
emails from many people many scientists
over the years condemning me for doing
both of those things speculating about
the future and also talking about
biotechnology in a very broad sense it
could be used for this purpose or that
purpose the third thing is that in a
field like biology it's very difficult
to bring it to a aller understanding
without simplification and so you have
to simplify if you want people to
understand it and I think that it
requires a scientist who has a much
deeper knowledge to do the
simplification because you know what you
can simplify and what you can't and
that's what I try to do but it means
that I'm not a hundred percent accurate
if I say that every cell in my body has
the same DNA I'll get attacked for
saying no there ourselves in the immune
system where the DNA is a little bit
different and my response will be well
you know if we get into all the details
you lose the big picture so there are a
lot of scientists who say you're not
being accurate you're misleading people
with their very narrow and then the
final problem is that some people are
jealous you know this guy's on TV how
does he have the right to be on TV and
i'm not even talking just about my own
work i'm talking about other people's
work how how dare i do that the other
people should be presenting their work
but the other people can't different
people have an ability or not to be able
to present things at Al a level so i
think that sort of summarizes what's
going on